are you guys doing very well thank you
very pretty crazy right I'm great
what this old is boring yeah whatever
that's fake this is a backdrop yeah so
obviously this is intended to be sort of
the end of the franchise that you guys
have built but right now it seems that
all the jam
everywhere is multiverse storytelling
and since you're both writers I would
love if you would just for fun pitch me
your multiverse version of How to Train
Your Dragon again jet lag let's get
weird
yeah all right so there's this thing
called the vortex knob and it's it's
it's it's in hiccups [ __ ] stomach and
and it allows him to go through a
different life where he's the dragon and
toothless is the one-armed boy that you
know tames him and forges a bond and
then at the end of it you find out all
of it even the first three films were
just a dream thank you fabulous hashtag
vortex knob that's going to trend oh you
got to give me something something yeah
we're living in the age of multiverse
yeah use Bartok the magnificent is your
way in
that's your jumpring
oh well you know these ideas have been
milked clean for my brain but I suppose
in terms of you know possible crossover
just seeing our dragons enter the world
of Game of Thrones and the last
remaining episodes I have to really kind
of throw things off turns out there
aren't just two dragons left but a few
others snake then through a time warp
hanging our Vikings into the the world
of the Seven Kingdoms I got another one
too the pusher trilogy that maybe it was
windy yeah yeah famous so shared
universe with with How to Train Your
Dragon you know so there was hiccup and
toothless and then roughly a thousand
years later there were Danish cocaine
dealers excellent you're welcome yeah
very family-friendly I love it nothing
kids movies like Nicolas Winding rapping
alright so I'm just about out of time
with you guys and since this is the end
and you guys have been on this franchise
for so long I'm curious now what is sort
of for each of you your new passion
project that you're working on mmm
it's it it I don't know that I can
really talk about these things but I do
have I have a hopper of about 25 ideas
that are in various you know States some
of them have written multiple drafts of
full screenplays and one in particular
is focused on Irish mythology I spent
four years in Ireland there and and so I
just love you know the sort of the fairy
folk and the Banshees and everything
else and that's that's definitely a
passion project of mine
awesome well I'm sort of in
post-production on my second feature
called random acts of violence this is
an adaptation of a graphic novel it's
awesome Thank You Dean and hopefully
it's scary and ruins people's ability to
dream normally
and then and then after that I writing
partner Jesse and I are working we're
doing a sort of cop show called night
Patrol which is a kind of a very
straight ahead sort of bullet French
Connection 7-ups kind of thing except
it's in Montreal between 1970 and 76 so
you have martial law declared in
Montreal the 1917 you had the Olympics
in 76 and then between is a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] so it's something that we're
really really psyched about and and
it'll be completely bilingual in French
and English so so yeah that's that's
what's kind of taking up my time and oh
yeah getting married obviously Oh first
she's a singer well congratulations guys
thank you for being good sports and
being willing to get weird on your toe
thank you and thank you for our crowd
with a humouring or crow me answer snow
wonderful